welcome Paul Schrader Willem Dafoe sit
down guys
hello yeah perfect perfect perfect how
are you guys doing all right
you think so
promotional tour so you Paul we're on
live right now by the way but you like
you're still in that mentality of on to
the next I mean you've been moviemaking
for you know and in the process of
moviemaking for so long you're still
like motivated to just keep making the
next one in the next one the next one
just the sheer curiosity of trying
something new you know Allison I didn't
film a couple years ago which we did
self-funded part of the challenge of
that was could we do it could we pull
this off now what we did pull it off
part two of the challenges could we do
it with Lindsay Lohan and we did pull it
off you know I'd never do it again you
know the challenge of a different
challenge to the next I was just talking
to will about what he's doing and in
Italy which is something he's never done
what are you doing in Italy next year
well I'm doing the theater piece you
know that's uh I would it's every time I
do a theater piece it's always different
every times i doing movie it's always
different that's one of the pleasures of
being an actor right I've never been to
Italy I gotta go myself it's interesting
oh I miss my shot yeah Paul I have to
ask you as a director and as a guy who's
a writer too if you were a writer no
poor guy
the right brush if you were making a
film right and some some kid who's got
one line in the say comedian has one
line in the film he's one yeah and right
before you start filming he approaches
you and he's rewritten the entire script
to create himself as a co-star and he
goes hey Paul I just had a couple ideas
once you let me know what you think of
this I rewrote it
it happened it has happened have you had
anybody do it oh yeah how do you handle
that usually with brutal honesty
you know and occasionally profanity
good but the other thing happens too
which is you have you know add a player
with one or two lines and you pull them
aside earlier in the day and say hey you
know there's not much here you two guys
you're playing cops you want to work out
something together and show it to me I'd
be you know maybe maybe we can make it
more interesting
yeah see is cuz Colin Quinn Crocodile
Dundee - but I was in Crocodile Dundee
to Idol line so I took the script I read
it found it a little wanting I made
myself the co-star with him the second
1987 whatever and then I handed it in a
one-line I handed it to the director and
a producer and they waited for their
response
I will reset there like it made it more
of like a New York type thing with me
and Paul out and running around because
the plot was New York he's realized what
a horse's ass he is and they they just
kind of you know they will astray
instead of like yeah you know about it I
was like I saw the movie I was like look
at these guys they blew it like they
could have done my version do you think
that was rude of them not to get back to
him I think very gracious they even
accept it yeah yeah yeah I would if I
would have definitely fired me in
retrospect well the time what would you
that like what have you found out that
you were on a movie set with somebody of
the audacity of a young Colin Quinn to
do something like that do you just not
want to deal with him yeah
what he wants it's creepy yeah if you
the guy who tried to write a trip self
out but uh yeah and my poor girlfriend
typing it away like acid give it another
lines having the type of mice I'm into
rope-a-dope you are yeah just let him
make the mistakes keep going keep going
keep going and then eventually he'll
just be out of your life that makes
sense that makes sense so the new movie
is called doggy dog it's at November 11
and it's a super it's a very trippy
movie how much of that I guess Paul was
in your head because there's a lot of
visuals going on in the movie so when
you're wouldn't you what do you see the
script and go like okay this is where I
want to go with this thing well this is
sort of beginning I I'm not a crime film
director I didn't really set out to make
a crime film I wanted to make another
film with Nic Cage because of something
that has happened and so this turned out
to be it and then the challenge was how
do you make a crime film in 2016 yeah
you know such a tires honor to ex-cons
the final job blah blah blah
and so now you're just trying to be
imaginative and trying anything and
unfortunately for me the best role was
this character Mad Dog but Nick said
that he had just played a mad dog and he
wanted to play the straight role so then
I could go to whelm and offer him the
crazy bro which was the best role and we
could reap ruiz wild at heart from 25
years before i you directed one of my
favorite movies blue collar and now what
was this set like well i mean the lot of
stories have been told yeah I mean you
know from the first week on it was
either some form of verbal or physical
confrontation who was the mate was it
was Harvey Keitel Yaphet Kotto Richard
Pryor they play Detroit Auto Workers it
was like 1978 who was the major well it
had to be Richard of course because it
really was one of the unhappiest people
I've ever met really and he had what I
called at that time the big in black
problem which is he wanted to be the
biggest entertainer in the world and the
blackest entertainer in the world well
you and I know it doesn't
work that way so that whenever he got
really big me popular
he would say class himself and get me
and get very black once he got me and
very black he would get disappointed
that nobody liked him and then he would
swing the other way right so
woof-woof-woof it's exhausting you know
it was exhausting to watch I can only
imagine what it was like to live how we
had it Yaphet Kotto and harvey keitel
deal with that they take well to it well
no I mean I especially my fault I had
invited three Bulls into a china shop
right and told each one they were the
alpha bull and then stood back was
either worse you've dealt with who was
he the hardest adult a Richard simply
because of the race race always makes
every ten accent come you know it throws
up everything I mean you can deal with
bad behavior you can irresponsible
behavior drunken behavior but race
behavior is another thing you know when
Richard winter says to you like Ritchie
said to me said the first white man I
ever met
came to my mama's door to [ __ ] her and
you're just like him I'm saying
arresting Richard I never heard what
that way that's kind of in a scenario
where you're not gonna win yeah that was
to put people off base or something or
take or catch you off guard or something
there's no other reason to say this well
I mean or or if you just live in that
jungles of of these things are pulling
you one way or another yeah yeah yeah I
read stories about that and it was such
a good movie you did you really write
taxi driver in three days no as I wrote
the college called me three days we
segue it has been saying the whole
Collin was half right I wrote two drafts
in ten days and I went right from the
end of the first draft to the beginning
again so I think the first draft which
was only 50 pages long was in three days
and then in the next seven days I wrote
it a longer version of the same script
which got to be regular length so the
that three-day version was essentially a
tone poem an outline right he just did
the outline Collin in three days it's
not the whole scripts a great
screenwriters know what really happened
croc Dundee - I wrote that yeah it was
about four days yeah okay well you know
I as a director when somebody says to me
I would like you to read my script I've
been working on it for two three years
you go oh my god no good I wrote in four
days and you say please let me see it
because anything that's going to come
out in four days has a reason to exist
right and Travis in there he's
embarrassed to ask here's what he wanted
to ask when De Niro said are you talking
to me and he kept repeating it did you
write that either he just do that
dialogue is barely ever ever written a
script that's just sort of improv is the
Tauri thing where you describe a
situation
Travis looks at the mirror has his gun
pulls out his guns talks to himself
pretends to be a bad guy and then
because if you write that stuff it'll
never be as fresh right as when the
actor kind of makes it up that was my
guest but he said no he probably wrote
out every word yeah that's what Travis
said but he though he's usually wrong he
certainly is wrong he's generally wrong
to fool so we'll see in the other room
because he's wrong there's a fountain of
misinformation so we have to keep some
distance from him
I figured as much yeah you're gonna be a
part of the new Justice League movie is
this true yeah how do you feel
doing the blockbusters because obviously
you were such a huge part of spider-man
and that was a monster of a movie right
as compared to stuff like like doggy dog
like which is more small-scale and I
would say experimental with a lot of the
stuff that's done yep
when you get into something that's a
blockbuster and you've got a lot of
cooks in the kitchen right
is that tougher for you is it boring is
it it's different you know the pace is
different yeah and you know when it
works well you know you get time to
refine things you if something doesn't
work you can reshoot it you have more
resources but of course with more cooks
and with more resources sometimes you
can overthink it and rice is kind of a
parallel to what Paul was talking about
writing the screenwriting sometimes with
films that have less resources and have
a very strong director and a good team
behind them you just get to it and there
isn't too much second-guessing so both
can work but I'd like to mix it up you
know and I'd like to be flexible every
time I start a movie I
I got a reinvent what it is that I do
and rethink it and that's what you want
to do yeah yeah I find that's the way
that you know where I find pleasure and
it keeps what I do alive rather than you
know a canned thing and you know I'm not
in the lockstep well it's hard to get
things through to like I have a really
good cop movie you I do I didn't know
that yeah you do oh yeah yeah it's such
a great crowd to talk about it's good
it's a black hop and a white cop and
they get thrown together as partners and
they don't get along and the chief is
always on them the whole I can play the
black
but they're both conceptual it's really
hot at the end yeah how quickly do you
know when you're making a movie well I'm
like when you get to set how quickly do
you know when you're like this one's
going to be a disaster I'm not gonna
question it goes without saying you
don't know you don't know I mean for you
you can have instincts about whether
things are functioning and whether
people are engaged and whether people
are shooting themselves in the foot or
not but I've even been on films that
didn't seem to be functioning
functioning and then they do people
really respond to him and vice-versa
films that feel really compelling to me
and I'm engaged and interesting things
are happening and then it comes out and
people just don't bite so you never know
what a favorite moment in platoon I
don't I don't do favorite mom come on
and that come on it's all I yeah one
moment leads to the next what can they
say thank God for not answering small
guys long yeah don't respond whatever he
says his favorite moment is please I
want silence in this
it's a lovely [ __ ] war gentlemen I
don't think it was in platoon oh that's
right so so you you don't know if you're
making a piece of [ __ ] but when when you
go to them yeah what did you say like
why should we say something look he says
some people don't respond to the
material you go thank you
you know when you're watching important
especially at night I can't see that
much of the big picture cuz maybe he's
worked two three weeks and other people
have worked ten weeks and he's
concentrating on his part of this
project but when you see it in a theater
or something and you're like god dammit
this is not great this is really [ __ ]
uh I can't even sit for this I cannot
write uncomfortable this is films 101
you know what it's really hard to do
it's really hard for me to see because
when you see film the associations of
making the film
strong and you're watching it and you
may say oh man that that felt so good
is that what it is yeah or the opposite
can happen to where I thought oh man I
remember we really struggled with that
that didn't work but here it comes
together some people respond yeah yeah I
mean this is why it's a good game you
know you can't you can't control it you
can only you know apply yourself and
hope for the best so yeah Paul how'd you
get involved with Raging Bull
that was the DeRose project neither
Scorsese or I were terribly interested
in doing a boxing movie look at us too
short asthmatic religious kids and but
De Niro had this obsession with it
and I was on the set I was finishing
shooting a movie with George Scott
called hardcore and the arrow came on
the set and so I knew he wanted
something because he never shows up
unless he wants something and so and he
had developed the script and he could
not get a green light so he asked me if
I would rewrite it and I found out
something very interesting when I
started researching it Jake LaMotta
hated his brother Joey so much then he
wrote an entire autobiography and never
mentioned his brother now the book was
based on Jake's autobiography so there
is no Joey LaMotta in the book no nor in
the script I start researching and I'm
saying here they are the the fighting
libellus Jake and Joey Wow and I said
this is a great this is a sibling story
you know they make this deal you know
one of them gets beat up the other one
gets the [ __ ] and they split the pot
that that's a formula for drama
so wait did they yeah I hadn't heard it
was his friend Pete that did it but I
didn't realize he hated Joey and that's
why he wasn't in the book Pete did the
the adaptation but the book itself which
Pete Savage was involved in writing
there is no Joey Labonte oh wow so they
did actually make up no never know
oh that was just for the movie
those were actors no we interviewed Jake
we was to use a little bit of a dice
univision his 90s but we asked I asked
him I think about the Brotherhood I
think someone said did she did he
actually [ __ ] Vicky he's like nah yeah I
mean they didn't make up in my timeframe
I don't know if they made up before joy
died hmm
well I'm Internet lore about you is that
you got kicked out of high school yeah
for making a porno is that true not
exactly you weren't in high school but
she was you know I made a little
magazine show and I interviewed some
people and when we were shooting it
there was some kind of racy stuff but
there's but there was nudity and are you
doing it like like with the high
school's equipment and all that Sarah
pissed they were pissed yeah yeah and I
you know someone went into my editing
room uh you know and whatever 16 years
old 17 years old and you know they went
into the editing room I wasn't going to
present this stuff but I wanted to be
free and shooting so we had a good time
and someone saw the rough footage and
that's a lesson for you they ran to your
editing so this must have been the time
the Living Theater when it was all
around yeah it's about that time but I'm
also very far from the living theater
because I'm a high school kid very
unsophisticated and happens in Wisconsin
just trying to make his way how do you
at 16 how do you convince girls to take
their tops off in movies Oh get in make
what he's really that years remember
ugly George no I
do you sure yeah who's a guy when when
there was public access TV a guy that
went all over and uh like a silver LeMay
a spacesuit with home video equipment
and he'd pick up women downtown that
were on their lunch break and get them
to an office somewhere and get them to
take off their clothes right and it was
interesting because um people did it and
just because of the camera just because
of the camera and it was new at that
time you know video stuff was new and
there was I think there was also Tehran
about you know just a strange
that's something wrong so what what
inspired you to do like how did you know
cause like when I was 16 I mean I'd be
too afraid I mean George they just put
it up yeah the other joke yeah but it
was kind of amazing um that show right I
was amazed how he how he could seduce
people into taking off their clothes and
you're like I did yeah it's as much
about how people secretly like to
perform and like to you know have
something rather than usual happened now
are you sure he didn't meet them before
and work this out because I see a lot of
porno where it's like they're meeting
girls on the street but oh yeah that's
before before the releases really are
yeah you just see yeah
yeah so you read my response to how easy
is it tell someone to take off their
clothes ask ugly George yeah it's not
that tough but what were you and like
inspired by him or like wait I could do
no no I'm a kid that you know sees 60
minutes when it's just first starting
and I'm playing with video equipment and
I'm gonna do three interviews of these
people but right but take your top off -
yeah that's great that's great
and then you went into experimental
theatre that was like the first thing
you're doing like that's what I read
what I still do experimental theater
explain experimental theater ah Timmy no
I'm it's a word that I would never use
but it's just not mainstream commercial
theater it's
the theater that I was involved with for
many years was the Wooster group right
for 27 years we worked a small company
that made their own pieces they were
theater pieces they had they weren't
traditional in the respect that the
structures weren't traditional they
weren't traditional psychology
traditional narratives used a lot of
visual things I don't know it's hard to
say exactly what it was but I can for
your audience and for us right now right
I can just say it wasn't your usual
Broadway play my see it's it's more like
like I'm Italian you're Jewish and we're
both in therapy in other words it has a
beginning beginning a middle and an end
but not in that order I see I see and
that's just what you liked it's what you
still like doing yeah because it's
different like you were saying before no
it's just you know it gets to what's
beautiful about theater I mean I think
the traditional theater is weighed down
by certain traditions of literature and
in psychology that doesn't tap into
what's great about theatre the event of
theater and he doesn't use all the
beautiful things about live performance
and I think there was a period and there
still is a period where some people are
working with those other elements that
tap into what's special about theatre
I tried theater they said I was just it
didn't work it was why didn't it work
I just like I would do like a funny line
and I was like look at the audience and
I'd want to get the credit from the
audience that's cute
I read an article that you wrote it was
from a few years back but it was an
article I think something to the effect
of what you know about women or
something like that you didn't I
probably did some little piece you know
it probably was a set piece in the
magazine that they you know is basically
a Q&A or something and that's how they
they turn it into that because that's
the form but it's basically just like
this I'm talking the latest movie to try
to get attention to it so people go and
see it right but
are you any but I don't need to write an
article about what I know about women
and say do you like to do the press for
a film or do you hate it some ways you
know listen I don't mind talking about
what I do I'd probably like it too much
and but after I do it and sometimes it's
engaging and sometimes you learn things
and it's fun and but sometimes you feel
really raped because you're at
cross-purposes because they have an
agenda and you have an agenda and it's
not doesn't serve the same purpose
unfortunately we've now entered the it
never ends
I mean promotion you mean yeah 30 years
ago you could do
Ted Kallen go you know at least ran for
bath you could do 20 spots and sort of
cover the media now you can do 20,000
and only have your foot in the door and
also also because of that there's
there's so much emphasis put on press
there's so much emphasis put on content
and finding breaking things that you can
talk talk talk talk talk and that will
never get covered until you [ __ ] up and
write a something really stupid and
that's what they run with so you wonder
why people promoting things get tight in
the end they try to control things and
can't speak freely it's because they
don't cover the body or of what it is
they cover just really the juicy stuff
because we're you know when I click away
soundbite world yeah like they're trying
to like it becomes a gotcha thing where
they're trying to get something out of
you that's that's scandalous so yes that
makes you tight you know yeah what kind
of guy was George see Scott Paul complex
it was at the time I worked with him he
was very angry but I suspect that was
probably true in general
he had just directed two films which he
had financed himself and both flopped
and so he was in a kind of sour mood and
that had turned him back on the sauce so
I did not meet him at his best
okay but he was extremely professional I
mean he said to me right at the
beginning he said he said I'll give you
a second take and if you need a third
take you can
for it but that's it because take 17 and
take one will be identical and they were
there were it's I like that you're I
heard Robert Shaw was like that on jaws
like they said someday he would come and
he would be like really raring to go and
other days he had had a few it was a
little a little tougher to get the shot
yeah yeah well Shaw was more of an out
of control I mean George was not out of
control you know in his in his contract
with Columbia his agent stipulated at
five days of no-shows presumably I do
too and it was exactly five days you
know he covered them off you yeah I did
five days but it wouldn't be more it
wouldn't be would be six Wow Wow
well listen everybody should check out
the movie the movies called doggy dog
it's in theaters November 11th fourth
well I see here's the problem on we are
in limited theaters look at look at look
at oh we have to yeah November 4th
limited November 11th yeah wider well
November for two cities November 11 10
cities there it is let's the platforms
so that's the on demand that the Amazon
yes
oh god damn world yeah it's a wild movie
I mean it's it's it starts with with
heroin and murder and then it just goes
from there Oh rom-com so I think you
guys are all very much enjoy it and it's
great to see at this stage in both of
your careers that you're still doing
stuff that's fun and new and relevant
and different and and inspired Thank You
Dean Colin no I wasn't talking about you
or Howard but thank you very much will
Dafoe and Paul Schrader it